le problème de la france c'est pas de
dépenser pour soutenir nos entreprises
pour qu'ils aient pas de faillite pour
qu'il ait pas de chômage ça bien sûr
quand il ya une crise le rôle de l'état
c'est d'être un bouclier un amortisseur
moi ce que je conteste en france c'est
que nous ayons le niveau de dépenses
publiques le plus élevé au monde et que
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
un exemple sur la santé nous avons des
dépenses de santé très élevée et
pourtant regardez sur la crise sanitaire
nous sommes au quatrième ou cinquième
rang de la mortalité
donc premier rang pour les dépenses de
santé
et malheureusement la mortalité est
élevée pareil sur l'éducation il ya
quelques jours on apprend que on était
là encore dernier de la classe
une fois de plus sur le niveau de maths
de nos enfants alors que on dépense
beaucoup d'argent dans l'éducation
nationale
donc à chaque fois c'est ça voyez c'est
pareil à bonne escient les français les
hommes politiques y compris parfois de
droite pensent que l'argent public
l'argent facile c'est la solution à tout
eh bien non en france ça commence à être
le problème des pensées mettre de
l'argent là où il faut en mettre
bien sûr pour rémunérer mieux nous
infirmières nos personnels soignants
mais on voit bien que quand un système
va mal vous avez beau mais des milliards
en plus c'est ce qu'a fait le président
de la république avec le ségur de la
santé si vous ne réformez pas les règles
ça ne vient pas ça ne marche alors je
conteste chez emmanuel macron c'est le
fait que quand il est devant un public
qui s'adaptent ils donnent les mots que
ce public veut entendre
ce qui fait que un jour il reçoit les
syndicats de policiers et il leur dit
vous êtes les plus beaux le lendemain
devant brut pour des jeunes qui pensent
que les policiers c'est horrible il dit
voilà les policiers il ya peut-être des
contrôles au faciès sous-entendu racisme
systémique
sous-entendu aussi les fameuses violence
il emploie le mot même si comme il le
dit le déconstruit mais fait rage aux
vestiaires exactement sur les violences
policières
donc vous ne pouvez pas faire ça tantôt
il est pour le nucléaire notamment pour
les centrales nucléaires
et ensuite il va fermer fessenheim donc
cette espèce de en même temps qui
devient une duplicité un double langage
cette sa désappointé france et ça fait
monter la colère parce que ça
décrédibilise la parole publique et
c'est la colère contre
les politiques qui monte ludique mais
aussi tout le monde et je pense qu'il ne
rend pas service
en réalité à la vie civique française
quand il le fait